ihre ansichten radikal konservativ gott
vaterland familie und eine harte anti
migrationspolitik
ich möchte zusammen mit euch versuchen
einen traum für diese nation aufzubauen
ein bewusstsein einen stolz auf das was
wir sind wie wir in der welt
wahrgenommen werden
george clooney hat gute chancen
ministerpräsidentin zu werden ihre
partei fratelli d'italia war bei den
letzten umfragen mit über 25 prozent die
stärkste ihrem mitte rechts bündnis mit
liga-chef matteo salvini und ex premier
berlusconi wäre die mehrheit sicher es
wäre ein rechtsruck satellit italia gilt
das post faschistisch in der nachfolge
neofaschistischer parteien
[Musik]
giorgia meloni setzt verstärkt auf das
wort postfaschist ich denn so mit sagt
sie praktisch ich bin danach getan und
muss mich also nicht rechtfertigen oder
etwas begründen diese geschichte ist für
mich passen
ich glaube nicht dass der faschismus vor
der tür steht ich finde es viel
interessanter zu fragen wer giorgia
meloni und fratelli d'italia heute im
jahr 2022 sind und was das über die
italienische gesellschaft aussagt
giovanni van acker und sein freund
giuseppe donato fahren zum fischen raus
in die straße von messina sie sind
politikmüde das ewige hin und her in
italien leid und unzufrieden mit den eu
fangquoten kleine fische angeln sie nur
noch bestimmte arten dürfen gar nicht
bei ihnen im netz lampen
es gibt viel thunfisch zum beispiel aber
den dürfen wir nicht fangen denn um den
fisch zu fangen braucht man eine
entsprechende fangquote für mein kleines
boot habe ich keine
es ist letztlich die eu die fangquoten
festlegt sie zur verwaltung weiter gibt
dann mitgliedstaaten wie italien
die werden an die großen verteilt meint
der fischer kleine wie er hätten nichts
zu sagen die erfahrung die er mit den
letzten regierungen gemacht hat man kann
nur den am wenigsten schlechten der am
wenigsten schlechte ist derjenige der
noch nie in der regierung war dennoch
nie die chance hatte die dinge in die
hand zu nehmen
merkator ascona einem markt messinas
geht giorgia meloni mit dem frust auf
die ebene auf stimmenfang
sie war mit ihrer rechtsextremen
fratelli d'italia immer in der
opposition
aggressiv gegen die regierung trage sie
präsentiert sich als die macherin die
probleme mit den eu fangquoten lösen
wird widerstand gegen einfluss aus
brüssel eines ihrer kernthemen
jetzt sagt man in europa macht man sich
sorgen wegen der meloni was wird dann
passieren was passieren wird ist der
spaß ist vorbei
dass auch italien seinen nationalen
interessen verteidigen wird wie die
anderen essen und dann nach gemeinsamen
lösungen suchen wird
[Applaus]
die hafenstadt ciampino in der toskana
hier wohnt das ehepaar luca barakat ii
und amalia man toll ihre stadt habe sich
verändert sagen sie
ein geschäft wie dieses zb das ein
wichtiges schuhgeschäft war wo viele
leute ihre schuhe gekauft haben musste
schließen
das örtliche stahlwerk bietet weniger
jobs als früher und in ganz italien sind
die reallöhne in den letzten dreißig
jahren nicht gestiegen
luca selbst verdient beim
sicherheitsdienst des hafens etwa sechs
euro pro stunde sagt er die menschen
verdienen immer weniger und damit gibt
es auch weniger geschäfte
wenn man was kaufen will muss man jetzt
woanders hinfahren
heute hat luca spätschicht kann am tag
noch mit sohn michael spielen der
39-jährige arbeitet schicht seine frau
amalia ist in einem supermarkt
beschäftigt der park um die ecke war
eigentlich immer ihr lieblingsort jetzt
fühlen sie sich hier im dunkeln nicht
mehr sicher
wenn die dunkelheit übernehmen und die
kinder gehen änderte sich dann kommen
andere menschen die eigentlich nicht
hier sein sollten
in den letzten jahren ist es dann
gefährlich geworden es gab auf attacken
nur frauen die ihren hund spazieren
führt
piombino war einst ein rote hochburg
heute regiert hier ein bürgermeister der
rechten fratelli d'italia auch luca
barakat die früher mitglied bei der
sozialdemokratischen jugend hat seine
ansichten geändert
mitte rechts versuchen wenigstens den
unternehmen und den familien zu helfen
und die grenzen zu schützen
während die linke nicht mehr das
bauchgefühl leute anspricht sie sprechen
nicht mehr von den menschen
er hat sich entschieden für giorgia
meloni zustimmen
viele fragen mich wen wirst du wählen
ich tue mich schwer aber jetzt gibt es
nur eine person zum glück eine frau
vielleicht ist es das erste mal dass
italien eine authentische ernsthafte
frau nach vorne bringt
das vertrauen in die bisherige politik
ist beim elo nees wählern erschüttert zu
experten gerade jetzt in der krise
[Musik]
es ist eine wählerschaft die durch die
krise stark verängstigt ist
[Musik]
sind wähler die schutz und sicherheit
wollen
also die agenda ist mehr von sorgen und
ängsten als von hoffnung und optimismus
geprägt
fischer giovanni cannata sie die wahl
fatalistisch vorher kämen alle politiker
auf einen besuch vorbei weiß er doch
danach ändere sich nichts wir sind
niemand und wir werden vergessen
sie sind das gewohnt zählen ohnehin
nicht auf den staat der sie doch nur
bevormunde sie sind davon überzeugt
verlassen können sie sich auf ihre
familien auf ihre gemeinschaft